hey everybody is Jessie today we're
gonna start on an entirely new project
so we're we may not be finished with the
last project we might come back to it
but right now there's just not a lot
going on with it and the things that
remain to be done there are other things
that we've done before sometimes
multiple times on the stream or they're
just not really a big deal so I don't
know that they were streaming but today
I want to kind of get you familiarized
with the site that will be working on
probably for for the rest of the month
and just kind of let you know some of
the background if you're interested I
did do some videos where we were trying
to fix this site a bit before so this is
on my my youtube channel so there's a
link in the description but the video
that's first ever live coding session it
I talked about this website in there I'm
pretty sure let's see the quality yeah
so the max quality is 720p and I think
the font size is too small so it was my
first session so I was kind of messing
things up a bit
but you can still hear me
so you can get an idea of what's going
on with this but I'm gonna try to
summarize everything and what we're
trying to accomplish so it's not
necessary that you go back and watch
that but if you wanted more info I think
maybe this video and maybe the next two
two or three live streams after are
about this site and this is a site that
I'm that we're working on it this is a
public site so Franciscan edu and it's
slow so there's other things wrong with
the site but for today we're gonna focus
on how slow it is
I ran a page speed test earlier and this
is what we got 29 out of 100 which is
good compared to what it was so when I
earlier this year I had some time to
work on this site and the score was
actually one so I'll have to find a
screenshot a pretty shot took a
screenshot of it this is the lowest
score I've ever seen if I can find that
I'll show you all but I'm pretty sure it
was it was one and yeah so it's better
than it was but there's still a lot so
you can see some are easy things like
just image reducing image sizes
compressing images some are things that
are a little bit more difficult and some
things we won't be able to change we'll
just kind of have to work with it so
things like server response time I don't
really have access to anything with the
server right now this it's a whole
different department where I work that
handles that so I won't directly be able
to change anything I can try to work
with the other department though to get
some things change so as you can see in
this particular test server response
time was 1.1 seconds that's not good
I've seen it as high as seven seconds
with this server and yeah so it doesn't
matter how fast we make this site we
still have to deal with this server
response time so hopefully I can do
something about that or at least talk to
people who can do something about that
also my camera keeps freezing so I will
I'll try to fix it I don't know what the
problem is but I came in today and it
was it wasn't working so there's some
command that I can type in to get it to
work but it's only working temporarily
so let's see all right let me let me go
to the live chat quickly just to say hi
before we get started
hey everybody
Oh is there Joseph says there's an apple
event going on my streaming doing it
during an event I've done this before
I should pay more attention to what's
going on but if I don't have a lot of
people I'm gonna blame it on that but
actually it looks like there's a lot of
people right now I mean more than more
than usual so yeah today we're going to
work with some stuff that we are we've
never worked with before so in
particular this this site was built with
a content management system called
Ektron and that system is based off of
dotnet framework and so there's some
c-sharp stuff I don't know how much
we're gonna get into c-sharp today but
we will get into it at some point so we
made we may start looking at it I don't
know how much we're actually gonna edit
let's see John B said no longer
camera-shy
yeah I'm trying this out I'm trying the
camera thing uh-huh John B says I reach
your camera a twenty nine out of 100
would can I look and I improve is it the
quality or is it my face I'm not all
right cool so let's get started
I always forget to do this at the
beginning but if you're just watching
for the first time though this stream is
just about me doing my everyday work so
it's not necessarily a tutorial although
I try to explain things as I
along and there are a lot of people in
the live chat that are very helpful
answering questions but I just want
other developers to see what it's like
for me to do my job I don't know if I'm
an average developer or not I don't
really know if my workflow is is the
norm but I thought it would be useful if
other people especially maybe people who
work on their own or who are just kind
of starting out could you see what it's
like for me see how many mistakes I make
and how I've worked through that and so
that's so that's what we're doing here
so if you do see a lot of mistakes if it
seems like it's unscripted that's kind
of the point so it's not scripted and I
will make mistakes so that said let's
get to it I like to organize the streams
with Pomodoro timer so I'll do 25
minutes of coding or you know whatever
kind of whatever we happen to be doing
it's not always code like right now
we're gonna be going through some of the
site speed things but I'm gonna do that
for 25 minutes so I'll take a
five-minute break and I'll go through
the live chat and answer any questions
you have and then we'll just repeat
today we'll probably do two Pomodoro
sessions I'd like to like to keep this
dream a little bit short I'm still
working on that react nanodegree and I
have a project a Redux project due by
Friday and it is not done yet so I need
to work on it so that's why I don't want
to do a really long stream I want to get
done and work on it a little bit a
little bit more okay so I'm just going
to start with some explanation of what
the site is what's what's wrong with it
what we're gonna try to change hopefully
you know by the end of September we'll
see how much we can get done all right
so this is the site the main site for
the university that I work at I'm a
front-end developer for Franciscan
University this site was built before I
started working here I think it it's a
three years old in terms of when it was
launched it's about three years but in
terms of development it's pushing four
years I think because the site was built
and went underwent a lot of testing and
things so it's about four years old and
it's definitely in need of some bigger
updates than we're gonna handle this
month but the completely redesigning
everything from the ground up is going
to be a project that's going to come
hopefully within the next year but not
not right now so right now we're just
going to try to make the best of what we
have all right and what we have as I
mentioned earlier is a site built off
the Ektron content management system if
you've never heard of ektron then I'm
not surprised because I never heard of
ektron before I started here and it's
it's a challenging content management
system to work with luckily I don't have
to do that much with it there are other
people in my department who handle most
of the content management with that and
I don't usually have to deal deal with
it directly but right now we've already
showed you the the site speed rating and
if you wanted to look at this in more
detail you could just run the site speed
test yourself on the site but the first
thing that we're definitely going to be
able to do is we're gonna be able to
compress some of these images but even
better than that what I think we can do
is actually get rid of some images so
let's see browser caching I don't know
that I can do anything about the caching
so things that I can't do anything about
I'm gonna hide we can try to eliminate
the render blocking JavaScript and CSS
I'll show you in a minute what we're
kind of what we're dealing with here in
terms of how this gets put into you know
by Extron you know how things get put
together so I don't have complete
control over over all the files some of
them are
created dynamically and just put in here
and there but we'll do the best we can
you see this there's quite a few files
being loaded here can't do anything
directly about the server response time
and we're gonna try to fix this you know
prioritize visible content but that's
that's going to need we need to do some
work also when it comes to minifying the
JavaScript I I can't
minify a lot of these directly because I
don't know where they're coming in at so
that's one of the bad things about
Extron is there's not really an exxon
community like if this was WordPress I'd
probably find 500 articles about how
something works probably more with
Ektron not so much the company that made
Ektron originally got bought out by
another company so I'm not even sure it
what the support is like with Exxon
anymore
and then minify HTML probably won't be
able to minify the HTML and uh if you're
if you're wondering why we can't do
certain things it'll be a little bit
more clear in a minute although I know
some of you are good with c-sharp Sarno
Umberto's good with c-sharp so maybe
some things that I don't think I can do
right now maybe we can do and I just
don't don't know how so anyway that's
what we're dealing with the biggest
images on the page are obviously the
images in this slider and they all load
so these there's no lazy loading going
on here all these images load and
they're all pretty big now obviously
they need to be a certain size if it's
gonna be you know a large slider like
this but some images are actually really
big and they don't need to be like this
image is one of the largest images on
the page but it's tiny right so there's
little things like that that we can
change and that really the the people
who are updating this site through the
content management system need to be
aware of
the size of images that they're putting
in and making sure that they compress
the images so we'll handle that I don't
want to do too much compression and
things and image resizing on the stream
because I don't think that's it's just
not really exciting stuff it might be
worth it just to go over how I do it but
I don't want to go through a ton of
images and do you know resizing and
things some of the images I think we can
get rid of are these I don't think that
we need these here and these are these
images are pretty big so each one of
these sections we could probably take
the images out completely we want to
make sure I did go through a few months
ago and made sure these images were the
correct size and compressed but it's
possible that you know some new ones
have been uploaded so we want to double
check that the same way this image
changes frequently so we want to double
check to make sure that image is is
working correctly I know the user
interface wise there's a ton of stuff I
want to change with this user interface
but the first thing that I want to worry
about is the the load times because if
if the page takes too long to load and
someone doesn't even stick around to see
it then it doesn't matter how nice it
looks it could be the best looking site
ever made but if it takes you know 50
seconds to load no one's gonna see it
all right so let me see if there's ice
want to see if there's any questions
quickly in the live chat about you know
but before we actually start to dig into
some of the some of the code so I'm just
going to quickly kind of scroll through
this and see if there's any questions
related to the site
okay all right cool it looks like
nothing related to this site although
John Hanson does say if you do a Google
page speed test they'll actually give
you the compressed files to download the
images yeah that's true I'm glad you
mentioned that
I'm see where they are at the bottom
yeah so you can download we do a page
speed test you can download all your
compressed resources so I have used some
of these before so we may we may get
some of these for the images I have I
use image magic on the command line and
I have I'm able to get better
compression than I can get from these
also we're gonna need to resize some of
them as well but it'll probably be
useful to grab some of this JavaScript
and CSS at some point you know we could
benefit ourselves but if it's already
done for us then you know why not use it
all right so we're just gonna deal with
the home page for now obviously that
gets the most visitors and it's also the
page that takes the longest by far to
load so some of the Interior pages
aren't quite as bad for load times so
we'll see how it goes if I don't think
we'll get this you know to where we
really want it in the amount of time
that we have but if we if we do we'll
move on maybe in work on some interior
pages I'm gonna be using sue I want to
bring this over so it's closer all right
there we go I want to bring I want to
show you my Trello board as well so I do
have a Trello board that I already made
a few months ago just a lot of things
that I thought could be done to help
with load time so you know we're gonna
we're gonna go through some of these we
don't have to come up with everything
you know on our own right now so you
know a basic stuff minify these files
but some of the things are
actually redoing the UI so that we can
get away with not having so many images
or we can completely get rid of some
pieces of code that for whatever reason
are slowing things down a bit this is
the file that we're going to be working
with mostly as you can see I'm actually
using Visual Studio code so I know we
always have peeps someone always asks
about my code editors so it's Visual
Studio code this time and not Adam so I
have we're mainly going to be working in
this file although you can see there's a
lot of different things linked into this
file so we're gonna have to dig into
some of these other files as well but
this is a copy of the the template that
is used for the home page so we'll do
everything in the copy so we don't mess
up the home page and when we get it to a
point where it's it's good we like it
then we can just copy it over or change
the name and use that instead for the
home page so just kind of scrolling
through quickly up here we're importing
so it's actually it's not it's not
really that in terms of organization and
what's going on there there's some
similarities to what we're doing with
react right we're importing a lot of
other great components I don't know what
the terminology is for extra honor for
for.net framework stuff but in terms of
the terminology that we've been using
with react you know we're importing
components up here and then down here
we're mixing HTML with some of these
other try to find it okay with some of
these these tags here right so we can
put in you know these things that we've
imported up there we put them in with
these tags and we pass props to them
right so it's it's really a lot like
react components it just at least
superficially I have no idea what's
going on behind the scenes and whether
it's comparable to react but at least
you know so the we can reason about it
that's basically what it is and I'm
probably gonna still use react
terminology because like I said I don't
really know what the exon terminology is
for this stuff and I don't really care
to learn it since we're not gonna be
using it for that much longer anyway
so let's go into let's go in into the
the code is controlling this this
carousel here so this is kind of like
the hero section carousel I want to get
rid of it I want it to be completely
gone right this that seems to me like
it'll have the biggest immediate impact
on load times out of anything else that
I could do or at least that I could
easily do because these are the largest
images I get rid of one oops actually
it's not even some weird stuff going on
there's they're like three or four
images I think four images so four large
images on the page can be gone we'll get
rid of that and we'll also get rid of
these so basically the eighth-largest
images on the page we're gonna get rid
of I think that's gonna have a huge
impact also wouldn't be a bad idea to
just do just a baseline to see what our
load times are so let's just check out
I'm gonna change my network conditions
here and throttle it let's go with let's
go with a fast 3G and see what it's like
on Fast 3G I like to slow it down just
so that I get a better idea of what it's
like for people with slower connections
and also you can kind of see things
loading when it's a slower connection
so I'm just gonna refresh and we'll see
see what we get
you see how slow that was right like
waiting for the response and the network
that was really slow all right so we're
still waiting I mean at this point it's
the page is usable but not everything is
loaded yet so you scroll down it's
pretty much everything was loaded we're
still waiting on some of these images
okay are we done now
yeah all right total load time thirty
five point seven five seconds so almost
36 seconds total load time right
obviously the page was usable you could
see content a lot earlier than that but
you know you still had this little thing
you know go on up here or whatever it
does with Chrome a humph
for for 36 seconds that's crazy that's I
don't know I don't know let you but to
me that's just really slow so let's
let's just see what took the longest all
right let's see what the biggest files
were so we have an image okay this is up
there and that in the slider but I think
that's the main image there and then we
have okay this is the one with the
president the university this one is
that image that's that's here that's
really small that should not be this big
right where this image is 370 kilobytes
it's crazy that first image one point
three megabytes that's completely
unacceptable
okay as we go down it gets better but as
as usual your biggest files or images
that's I mean unless you have video on
your site your biggest files are
probably
always going to be images you can see we
are loading some bigger JavaScript files
so jQuery UI
completes right I wonder if we really
need that or if we need we need
everything there I'm interested to see
if that's okay at least it's minified
that's that's good that's crazy that
it's still that big even minified though
we'd see these anything that says banner
those are those big sections here right
so they're kind of towards the top as
well we want to get rid of that okay it
looks like there's there's no surprises
I was kind of looking for something up
towards the top that would just be you
know really big but it's not not bad I
mean I expected it with the images so so
that's definitely I think where we need
to goodness 24 seconds for that Wow
that's where we need to look first
that's we're gonna have the biggest
impact okay oh I did I just looked over
the live chat quickly and
I noticed that my camera stops I'm
resetting that again if anybody ever has
it has had issues with an iMac camera
just all of a sudden not working right
like the little green light just goes
black and bright in the middle of me
doing stuff it's right on the main
screen
- hmm excuse me
it's yawning my secondary screen I
haven't had any problems with that but
the angle is weird so you just see like
the side of my face the whole time so
anyway I'll probably end up getting a
like a USB webcam at some point so it
shouldn't be a problem for that much
longer but for now it's just a little
annoyance but I also saw Nova blow asked
why I'm in incognito mode because I I'm
an administrator for this site it
automatically logs me in and I don't
really want to lock myself out on when
I'm using Chrome not in incognito mode
and other files get loaded and so I
don't want to mess with the
administrator type you know files that
get for the UI for the admins I just
want to see what other people see so
that's why I'm doing it in incognito
mode
it also allows me to switch right over
it so I usually have the same site open
in normally in Chrome with the admin
features there so I can switch over and
change things really quick without
having to log in and log back out every
time I look at this site I just see more
things that I don't want to fix and
change okay
so let me show you if we're gonna take
this out we need to replace it with
something right we can't just completely
remove it that would look kind of weird
let me show you what I'm thinking of for
the replacement yeah sorry
yawning again I don't know what's going
on I don't think I brought it over yet
but still be on my other screen all
right so let me show you what I'm
thinking so this this obviously when you
see it you're gonna know why I'm saying
this obviously isn't gonna be what we
put in here but just kind of the basic
structure is gonna be more what we use
so let me try to do as much of side by
side as I can so right now you see this
is the the header here's our menus not
not really a fan of this too much here's
what I'd like to to move it to and this
should look at least somewhat familiar
since this kind of the same style is
what we used on our last project but I'd
like to switch over to this I think I'll
take this logo out and use our new logo
that we used on our last project when I
did this before I don't think I had the
new logo yet so that will change but
you'd see I've moved the header I move
some stuff around on the header I think
it looks looks more clean I've had
actually added some of the social media
icons so I think it looks a lot nicer I
Shrunk the search search bar a bit and
added a lot of things in the sidebar so
you can see all those menu items are
still there but now they've moved over
over here okay and we have search over
there as well if you're interested in
how I did this
check out those videos on my channel
that I showed you at the beginning
because I do go through a lot of how I
did this header and how I did this this
background so it's it's really simple I
mean it's a simple like parallax style
background but I'm thinking right now we
have four big images and sometimes we
have even more images on here just
depends on how many are uploaded at any
given time so we'll go from that down to
one large image so we'll still have a
hero section we just won't have all
those images so this is just a stock
photo obviously we also have and you can
see I didn't finish this right we have a
spot for you know for some text a
call-to-action button right and then
below obviously I haven't read I haven't
finished this but you can see I've gone
with a full-width wow that's weird
that's really weird I haven't seen that
happen before
hmm that's crazy
I've honestly never seen that happen
oh is that I don't know what I'm I don't
know what happened there I guess I
turned off that that's server yeah all
right
oh that's why so I I didn't have any of
my NPM modules installed for that
project and so my gulp server wasn't
running so anyway I'm gonna I'm
installing things on my other screen
here so but did you get the idea of kind
of what I want to do is just kind of
redesign this section here so I can get
rid of these images I'm also gonna be
able to get rid of a lot of these images
as well so look we have you know we have
more images here and it'll clean things
up there and I mean we're gonna get rid
of at least a dozen images so definitely
gonna be it's gonna be a lot more light
wait and see looks like
for some reason my my install fails all
right then so I'm getting some area that
I've never seen before
I'll give it another shot see if it
works not really a big deal we can still
do a lot of this without mmm just own
that again shoot okay so my um my timer
went up so now is a good time this to
break for five minutes I'll go over the
live chat and then while I'm doing that
let's see
yes I'll bring this over to so y'all can
see what's going on here all right so
check that out I'm in tonight hopefully
you won't see the air again but if it
comes up you'll see it don't ya so
all right so I may just have to that's
really weird
I just have to check that out later on
all right so I'm going to scroll up a
bit and I'm gonna go through the live
chat answer questions for five minutes
and then we'll go back and try to
actually get changed some things on this
page okay Michael will Avila says give
me a shout out so actually just shut up
anyway so there's a shout out so thanks
for watching thanks for for being
involved in the live chat
all right Patrick says he sharp for the
win not but I hear dotnet core 2 is
really fast as opposed to older dotnet
tech yeah unfortunately this is older
dog net tech so so not to me working
with the new cool stuff yet
yeah
all right I'm just I'm still scrolling
through trying to find some questions
here in the live chat
okay so des es says just starting out
and want to get in the IT world is
front-end or back-end the best or ideal
way to go I think it honestly depends on
what you're interested in
I don't know I guess I've I've seen or
either read about examples of people
starting with either front-end or
back-end and then sometimes they moved
to they switch sometimes they go full
stack I don't know it really does depend
on what you're more interested in as to
where you want to start out you could
always switch yeah I guess it would be
hard to answer you know in general from
what I've seen and this is you know I've
not studied this you know but just from
like casually observing it does seem
like salaries for back-end are slightly
higher than for front-end but I don't
know if that's just if that's true
across the board or you know just the
few times I've noticed it so I don't
know that could be a factor for you
rune grin shoe says learn front end
stuff somewhat well then learn back-end
then combine and improve join B says
depends on if you prefer working with
routing and networking or if you prefer
working with design and user interfaces
front-end is UI back-end is routing a
networking Verito says I don't think I'm
ever gonna be very good at front-end
design just not something I'm very
interested in or good at for that matter
yeah I'm Berto I would say if you're not
interested in it then there's really
probably not much reason to try to try
to work on it but if you did want to get
better at it I think it's one of those
things that it's
takes time right it takes a long time to
just get that I to look at something and
say and I'm not saying I have this
perfectly but just comparing myself to
where I was like let's say five years
ago to be able to look at a website and
immediately start to pick out places
where the design could be improved
whether there's just obvious things or
to be able to look at a blank page and
just start to visualize where everything
would go I that just takes a lot of time
of being exposed to it I don't know I
kind of think that you get all this
information in your brain from seeing so
many websites and trying to think
critically about them and then at some
point it's just it just kind of happens
naturally all right it's not like it
seems like you're just good at it but I
don't think it's the case that people
are just good I think it's that your
brain gradually gets used to picking
those things out so anyway that's just
my my take on it all right I'm going to
go back and do some more coding I said
we're gonna do one more Pomodoro session
and then then I'll answer the rest of
the questions and let's see I will say I
do want to give a little elaborate a
little bit more on what I was just
talking about especially for people who
are just starting out I I've seen and
maybe you all have seen this recently
there's a like a little comic that I've
seen online too where somebody's a
writer there's two people talking to
each other and the one one person is
saying you know I how do I get to be a
better writer like I'm still no good I
think it's writing and maybe it's an
artist I don't remember but he's asking
someone more experienced and a more
experienced person just as like just
keep practicing and the person says well
what I've been practicing look at all
the stuff I've done and it shows a pile
of work you know pile of papers and the
other person's I think says something
like well we'll just just keep going
and that you see their pile and it's
huge like you know it's it's way bigger
than the other pile so I think it's kind
of the same thing when it comes to
coding it can be applied to that that
and and I don't think it's just like a
design thing or a front-end thing I
think it's any area it just takes a ton
of practice before you start to get
really good at it and again I'm not
claiming that I'm even at that point of
being really good at it there's
definitely a lot of things that I'm Way
better at than I used to be but there's
certainly more room for improvement and
I always likes like sports metaphors
sometimes are easy sometimes easier to
think about it in terms of like a
physical activity because the results
are just so obvious right in front of
you but I know they used to tell me when
I played American football and in high
school the more you practice so I was I
was a quarterback and they said the more
you throw the more you you get to see
what's going on in the field from you
that quarterbacks perspective things
they'd say it would they would slow down
right so initially like when you're
trying to find if someone the receiver
is open to throw the ball to it just
looks crazy and confusing but you just
have to do it so many times and
eventually your brain you get so used to
it it doesn't seem as chaotic it slows
down right and so I think it's it's the
same way like you look at code and it's
not just this jumble of mess you see
what's going on you can follow the flow
of it you look at a website design it
you see what should which should be
there so anyway that was meant to be
like somewhat encouraging that like if
you're not there yet don't feel like
there's something wrong with you you
just need to keep going although I guess
you could take it as daunting as well
thinking like wow I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to do the ton of work but anyway
let's get back to this also I did have
an issue all this morning I was working
on this bug and I just want to share
with you in case somebody runs into a
similar situation maybe it'll save you a
lot of time so I was sending form data
to a Google sheet and then saving it in
a spreadsheet and emailing it from there
but what I was doing I was taking the
form data and serializing it and then
sending it well one of the pieces of
data was the value of a text area and
occasionally we wouldn't get all the
data it would cut off in the middle of
what someone was trying to send and
right obviously that's a problem because
we wouldn't get all the information that
we needed and I could not figure it out
and I was trying to figure out what
browsers it was and testing on different
browsers and trying to look things up
couldn't find any information on text
areas getting cut off finally I went
back in and looked exactly at where
everything was getting cut off and it
was getting cut off right at a point
where they were using and so they were
using an ampersand and when a date is
serialized it just dropped everything
after that because it assumed everything
after that was was like part of the next
piece of data so I had actually just
went through and before I sent it before
I see I realized that I went through and
changed all ampersands to two and so a
and B and I put it in there so that was
the fake so if anybody ever has data
being dropped like that and you're from
forums
maybe it's that check check that out so
I don't know why I never thought about
that when I was first doing that that
form but really glad I found it snakes
that I had to spend so much time to find
it but it feels good when you find out
the solution to to a bug so anyway not
related to this project but could be
helpful for someone
oops
all right so I said something's wrong
with this I did have this running in
basically I had it I had it in a
different directory so everything that I
had done before was a branch on another
git repo and I wanted to make it its own
get repo so I moved basically I moved it
over a copy and pasted a bunch of stuff
I initialized a new git repo and then
for whatever reason now it's not it's
not working right so I'll have to that's
why it did work before and we could see
it at first but now I'll have to work on
that okay so let's go in now what we
need to do we need to find where the
data is being pulled in for this header
and where it's being pulled in for this
as well right because it's not most of
the stuff is not directly in that master
template it's in one of the components
that are being imported so we're gonna
have to do a little bit of digging and
this file structure is not it's not well
organized this this file structure has
been worked on by multiple people over
years before I even got here and so it's
a little bit it's a little bit crazy
just as an example we have all these
different configs and they're named
original config original older config
this is actually another copy called web
may 7 text and it's it's a text file but
it's just a copy of the config right so
there's not even a standard like naming
convention or anything so it makes it a
little bit difficult to find things but
at least we'll have we'll have some
hints here because we can look at what's
being imported here okay so main nav I
if I had to guess I'd say main nav was
probably
that navbar that we're looking for let
me know if this the font is too small
for you I can make it bigger and let's
see
hmm
we'll probably need we need to actually
I'm not gonna bring in so I think we can
strike a balance between things that we
pull in that that it's data from the
from the content management system and
things that we can hard code in I'm not
opposed to hard coding in this case
because we're this is just a kind of a
temporary thing to make the site a
little bit more bearable until we can
redo the site so things that are not
likely to change like our social media
URLs I have no problem at all hard
coding those so could probably safely
just get rid of this at some point hard
code the social media links and those
aren't gonna change but let's try to
find this main nav and I do want to
scroll down to the point where that nav
comes in at to see if I want to see
where that that slider is is is coming
in it as well so let's scroll down a bit
we're still at some strip things so you
see there's a lot of different just as
we scroll there's a lot of different
JavaScript stuff going on things being
being imported different places so we
can mess around with this and try to
move them around for you try to move
them around a bit see if we can increase
load of times just by maybe pulling in
some of this stuff you down at the
bottom
okay all right
okay oh and the utility now this is
interesting so it looks like a few of
these knobs are kind of put together so
we may need to work on all of them okay
so that's the top section now this is
where
okay all right so everything that's
that's between the footer and the header
is all in a difference a different
component
okay let's go check out that that Navin
so we'll go to user controls main of all
right we can look this will probably be
faster
there we go
all right so I mean
okay look say we got some jQuery going
on at the top for the search for the
search box which we should be able to
get rid of most of it
okay here we go yeah we're in the right
spot now we can see the different the
different links here
actually we could see and this is kind
of odd when I first looked at this I was
not sure what was going on but here's
what what happens so we can see all this
HTML and it looks like this stuff is
hard-coded but at some point it pulls in
the data from the content management
system so all this hard-coded stuff up
here doesn't really mean anything this
is what's important and this is
basically our components and then props
are getting passed in after data is
being pulled from the content management
system so this is what we need to worry
about and this is what I wanted to see
because what we want to do we're going
to totally change you know the HTML of
that header to make it match what we're
doing with our header and our side nav
so I want to be able to grab these and
input them in and I need to figure out
so okay that's you know what are they
doing here obviously if this was react
right I'd I'd be pulling in data and
mapping over it and things like that
well I'm not exactly sure how to do that
and with this so it seems like we can
use this repeater and that will loop
through everything
so there's definitely some stuff going
on that I'm just like I'm not sure about
but how do we have nested item templates
here what does that even see so there's
weird stuff that I'm just not not
entirely sure what's going on with that
Wow that is a very long string of data
there
[Music]
okay I'd say what I ought to do then is
bring in actually I'm gonna look at the
live chat quickly to see because I know
there's some of you that use that
possibly could be more familiar with
this just going to check briefly
okay I'm there to asked if this was
there's a repo I think I think I saw
that somewhere now I can't find it again
Oh a lot of this stuff isn't a private
repo right now I can probably pull some
of it at least some of it I think could
be in a public repo repo yeah it would
just have to be limited yeah I'll have
to double check and see what just to
make sure like you know cuz there's a
config file and stuff in here that has
like database passwords and things so
I'll have to double check and see what's
actually committed to the repo and if I
can make it public
also someone was talking about errors
okay lose john john hanson saying there
are 71 errors on that page browsers will
have have to perform error correction
wait there are 71 airs on tweets on this
page 379 airs
are we talking about something else
okay Tom asked what is a SC X to be
honest with you I don't know what it
stands for but basically these are these
are templates so if you want to think in
JavaScript terms and react terms this is
kind of like if you had a dot JSX file
and I mean that's really a loose
comparison right because I'm admittedly
I'm not really familiar with this so I'm
not I'm just trying to learn as much as
I I can as much as I have to to make
these changes so it's going to be a lot
of trial and error but I imagine this is
not this is not that uncommon that you
would come into a project that was
already existing projects kind of like a
legacy thing and I have to work with it
and not really have a lot of freedom to
change things drastically so that's what
you know that's what we're gonna have to
do so what I want to do right here I
think is copy and paste a bunch of this
stuff and then
I don't know about this search right now
I didn't really want to bring in all
this this jQuery but maybe I'll bring
I'm not worried about the search right
now I can bring that in later but let's
let's pull in I have to find that that
other template or was it there yeah okay
so usually I want to pull in
all right i need's need to format this
it's easier to read so let's just it
format is HTML for now okay
okay so this is where we were pulling in
Main Ave so let's comment that out for
now
and then put some of this in here and
let's see what it does and I need to
figure out
I need to figure out what URL this test
page is at
I don't remember okay cool so we have an
answer so ASC X is the file extension
for asp.net or asp.net not really sure
how you're supposed to pronounce it but
I'm going to say ask because that seems
like it would be faster
says basically a scx makes it files make
it easy to use the same code across
multiple asp.net web pages cool alright
let's
I can't remember tents sorry everyone
I cannot remember what the URL is for
the test version of this because I made
it in at the beginning of this year and
I haven't been on it for a long time so
let's see I'm gonna look it up here so
on my other screen I'm in the content
management system I don't want to show
you this right now because I don't want
to show something that shouldn't be on
like in terms of May there might be
content that's scheduled to be released
that shouldn't be public yet I don't
really know I don't use this often
enough to even know if that's if that's
a thing but just in case
okay I was close
all right cool so I got it so here's
here's the page and you all can go to
this this is public Franciscan ddu slash
home test and we've got an error which
is cool I kind of expected we get some
air because we just copy and paste at a
ton of stuff that to be honest with you
I didn't completely understand anyway
just you know million Li because of the
syntax that I want it used to but let's
see we're line 352 line 352 so there's
this that's the first line that we
actually put put this in so let's get
rid of a lot of this stuff oops
okay let's get rid of that since that
was all I can see now that this looks
like it was commented out anyway
alright now let's see if we can figure
out why that's not working we have
I'd say that see
and in case you you notice this we are
in fact cowboy coding right now so there
really is not a test version of this
site
I can't do anything about that that's
just I know that that's that's not good
but there's supposed to be a beta
version of this site but unfortunately
it shares all the same files I'm not
really sure I think it has a different
database but all the files are the same
so if I go to change a file for the test
version it also changes things on the
live version so for our purposes we're
editing the live version of the site and
there's not really anything that that I
can do about that
okay let me check again sis's
okay the name Chow has taxonomy does not
exist in the current context
alright so probably you copy something
over whoops
hmm I lost some other file let's split
this
let's check out
there we go shrink that give us a little
bit more space I don't think I clicked
on the wrong thing there we go
there actually let me see this as well
this each dot aspx page has this dot CS
page with it so there might be some
things going on here yeah I think there
are some definitely some things going on
here that that's probably the reason why
we're getting the airs so it's just as
child excellent yeah there we go
so it's not enough that I just copied
that over because I didn't bring over
any of this stuff and so let's see
I think this yep if I just bring this
over
I wanna see if if that will work I'm
thinking there might be some problems
with the with the path but it's worth a
shot
we'll see I don't know if it'll work
yeah I can't put two of those in there I
may have to leave this as a separate
component and then just edit the
component
yeah so what we probably should do then
is make a test version of this nav
component and then we probably won't
need a test version of the the CS file
we can just link that CS a CS file up to
our test component and then in our our
main test dot master we can pull in that
component our test main nav component
make all our changes in that otherwise
if we try to change the main ave s CX
right now it will change on the live
site so I don't want to mess with that
so let's see let's make a copy of this
I mean that one I'm gonna rename that
test okay so we get main nav tests and
now we should be able to pull this in
let's just yeah and as long as we don't
change that tag name we won't even have
to change it down there so we're pulling
in we're importing like I said I don't
really know the correct terminology but
in terms of like react terminology I
guess that were used to we're importing
this main nav test component as main nav
so we can refer to it as main nav and we
can remove yeah yeah so glad I didn't
take that out so you see where we're
pulling in that main nav right there as
the component now let's get rid of all
this other stuff that we pulled in that
won't work and this I mean I think that
was we pulled that in as well
oops no we didn't sorry okay
there we go so let's save that shouldn't
we shouldn't have errors now
all right awesome okay cool so we pulled
that in it works let's before I stop and
answer questions I just want to verify
that this in fact does work by changing
something preferably something obvious
see you can see I had already in the
main file I've removed all the stuff
that goes this going on down here so
that we could build it from scratch so
that's why there's nothing there right
now all right so let's let's go to that
test file and let me I'm gonna get rid
of that so I don't accidentally change
anything on it and our main nav test and
we can
let's change something
I was hoping there was something
hard-coded somewhere in here
it's nice I was green background
yeah let's just switch it okay so the
placeholder right now says search with
three dots let's take out the three dots
so search you see search with three dots
Wow these load times are gonna annoy me
all right see now the three dots are
gone so that works so we did pull in a
copy of that component that's our test
component now we can mess with it and do
whatever we want to it and we won't have
to worry about messing up the live site
just to to verify let me bring over the
live site you can see this is the
version with the admin stuff in but you
can see this still has the three dots so
now we have two completely different nav
components being used all right well
didn't get that much done visibly but
got a lot done in terms of just
understanding how this works
so that the next time we can jump in and
just really start messing around with
the components and pulling things in and
you know just kind of reworking this
page the thing we'll have to remember is
just to make sure that we make copies
test versions of everything and just be
really careful that we don't edit
directly one of the files that's being
imported into the main live version I
should say they're all live but into the
version of the site that most people see
okay let me go to the live chat now if
you and this portion of the stream I do
a question and answer so if you have any
questions put them in the live chat if
you're not interested in the
question-and-answer session thank you so
much for watching totally understand if
you get other stuff you need to do
and I'll probably be back tomorrow
actually there's a slight chance that I
may take time off work to work on my
nano degree project so if I do then
maybe I won't be back tomorrow but we'll
see hopefully I won't have to all right
so I'm gonna scroll back up to the place
where I left off at in the live chat and
I'm just gonna go down through and try
to get to all the questions that I can
also let me know what you all think
about kind of this streaming this
project in particular I don't we talked
yesterday briefly about it I don't
really have you know I don't have full
control over all the projects I need to
work on but I could try to maybe work on
something else during the stream if you
think that this won't be great I I mean
it's gonna be there's definitely gonna
be some stuff that can be applied to any
project like when we get into you know a
lot of the CSS and different things I
mean that's going to be useful
information but things that are very
specific to this content management
system probably won't be that useful
since it's not really a a widely used
system so I don't know I'm open to it
but at this point I don't really have
like I don't have another like from
scratch project that we can start from
the beginning right now I will have some
that I'll be working on later on
probably but probably not so like
towards the middle of October or
something so for now we'll see just let
me know what you what you think and I
can't guarantee that I can really switch
up what I'm doing but I can I can try
okay John Hanson says I've always been
curious about the render blocking CSS I
believe much of it has to do with first
paint and above the fold content yeah
yeah basically if you can the way I try
to handle it sometimes is if I can I
pull out all the CSS necessary for that
above the fold content and I put it in a
style tag at the head all that other CSS
I moved to the bottom and I just import
it in the bottom and that seems to give
me like a really quick initial load at
least in terms of what users will see
you know immediately they see they both
fold stuff the odds of them actually
scrolling down to try to see other stuff
that may not be loaded yet are really
low so that's work for me it doesn't
work on every site sometimes you know
bigger more complex sites it's hard to
like really get in there and look at
your CSS by hand and pull it out but on
small sites I've had I've had good luck
you know doing it that way
breanne says hey there hey how's it
going pretty sure I remembered to say
your name right this time let me know if
I didn't know bear says PHP can
dynamically resize the picture yeah I
could do it but the up one of the other
things is I I can't really run I I'm
like just really limited in what I can
do on this server so I'm not even sure
if I could run any PHP and actually in
fact the department that has control of
this server someone higher up in that
department is actually really anti PHP
so I probably would not have permission
to do any PHP stuff on any of their
servers so hmm I'll recognize I don't
know if you can hear my phone ringing I
do not recognize the number so I'm not
gonna answer that just probably somebody
trying to sell me something John Hanson
says there's just too much on that
homepage get the virtual scissors out
yeah for sure
I yeah it can definitely be cut down
how John Hanson says that is slow yes it
is it is very slow Patrick I'm not sure
how to pronounce the last name but it's
a different Patrick than the other
person that I usually refer to as
Patrick so I'll call I'll say Patrick
Kay Patrick Casey says what is the
software you're using for diagnosing i'm
on mobile can't see the name I think I
was just in dev tools yeah we ran she
says was dev tool so it was just chrome
dev tools at the time
oh cool so no beer did mention I had
said I got a question earlier about why
I was in incognito mode and no beer says
it's good for like cash problems
sometimes you can get around that by
using incognito mode so also a good
reason to use it
okay so I go says Jessie I've been
through almost two weeks in the
university computer science I have to
say math sucks the dropout rate is
incredibly high we learned to code in C
on Linux from scratch that's my
experience over four so far Wow
yeah that sounds that sounds rough I
know I'm not a big fan of math math I
can do math I got decent grades in all
my math classes but I just wasn't happy
doing it code in C I haven't really done
much with C I've seen some things done
with C it seems like seems like things
that you take for granted in other
programming languages you have to do
like manually and C and that seems like
it would be very tedious so good swears
the best tutorial for learning chrome
dev tools I don't know if you check out
the chrome the google chrome Developers
YouTube channel
they actually have some big people who
have worked on chrome talked about some
of the features so I would start there
I'm sure there are some other tutorials
that are that are good but that's what I
usually watch that when a new feature
comes out I just check out what the
chrome developers say about it I mean
they're usually really good at
explaining it since they built it so
yeah I would definitely check that out
jonbi says in response to I ghost about
computer science and math and everything
is math is hard but very useful to know
as for learning see I will say that that
will be very very useful when you get
into learning systems programming and
operating systems cool yep yeah I would
say I mean definitely hang in there
programming is programming so even if
you learn a lot of the basic stuff on a
language that you might not be that
interested in or you might not you know
see the benefit of it all the concepts
will transfer well to any language so
you know whatever you end up doing later
on it won't be a waste to have learned
you know whatever language you're
learning in your computer science
program and I know a lot of computer
science programs that I've had
experience with will teach things in
languages that are kind of really old
languages and at first it seems like why
would you teach this but as I said I
think it's getting the concepts of
programming down problem solving things
that's what's what's more important
it's like I guess is having trouble with
the calculus calculus killed me in
college that was it was pretty rough XE
I ended up just barely getting a B in
that class and the teacher was very
lenient with me in that but yeah I was a
business major and I was in the class
with all math majors and so that didn't
help either that they were just they
just got everything and we're flying
through all the lessons and I was like I
haven't taken a math class in five years
uh so uh it was kind of rough
okay all right so there's some more
discussion about some details of
calculus which I'm gonna skip through a
little bit here
and it's
alright sunshine - sure okay I
rearranged you had some advice for the
era I was getting when I was trying to
load when I was trying to run yarn and
load all my NPM packages so thank you
for that I'm gonna I'll try that after
the the streams over
let me know beer says did you work I
mean job or do you work I mean job so
I'm not sure if no beer is asking me or
somebody else because I did skip through
a bit of all that calculus stuff so I'm
not sure so anyway no beer let me know
I'm not sure if you were asking that who
you were referring to in that question
okay Antonia said good evening the text
is too small
oh sorry about that was it the text I'll
have to make this text bigger I'm get
I'm assuming that you're talking about
the text here although I can first
definitely think the text on this page
was too small which I wasn't really
worried about because the content on the
pages doesn't really matter to what
we're doing but yeah but let me know if
anyone else thinks this the text here is
too small and I can make it bigger yeah
I'll have to met like as you all know
who've watched before I don't use visual
studio code often so I don't have my
it's not really set up the way and in a
way that's comfortable to me yet so I
have to get used to it
Nova glow says can you do a video
working with SharePoint designer I don't
know I haven't I haven't done anything
the SharePoint before I don't foresee
anything in the near future that I would
need to do on there but I if there is
then I'll try to do video on it
okay
betterto says I want to clone this
project and port to port it to MVC spar
spar will says hi everyone
noob here hey how's it going thanks for
watching
okay it looks like so Umberto has been
having a lot of trouble with the screen
being fuzzy I'm assuming that that's
your connection is is anybody else
getting low quality because the the
stream health has been good the whole
time and yes I mean I've been outputting
the right number of kilobits per second
so it should be okay but let me know
okay onk it says so are you a freelancer
working for the university or do you
have a full time a full day time job
yeah I work full-time for the University
so I am employed full time here as a
front-end developer I do some freelance
work as well on the side though
so my camera froze for a while back
there and that tone Tony says best
freeze face I've seen for a while it's
usually it's like mid sneeze or
something yeah I did notice it just
froze again I did notice that it wasn't
a bad freeze I was like smiling and
somewhat looking at the camera so could
be bad
I gotta get this camera thing fixed
because I could definitely see it
freezing up and me just looking really
silly and not realizing it all right
Umberto's says the job I'm waiting back
on they're going to offer it to me this
week is to convert 14 JSP and Java
console apps to dotnet I'm so looking
forward to that's pretty cool
definitely that let me know how it goes
like if if you get the job and and how
everything goes with that I don't really
have experience don't anything like that
but it sounds interesting
no BIA says you're telling that your
connect to FileZilla or some similar
software yes so for this particular
project I'm not using FileZilla I
actually I have all the files from this
server for the website or what's the
word
I can't remember so basically I'll just
I'll show you how it works
right I it's mounted right so this
server is mounted to my file system so I
can just go right in there
I even have like let me see if I can
find it
[Music]
yeah so in this case like I'm in the
file structure for this and I can just
go right in there right for my machine
so that's how I'm kind of in the server
right now the downside is I can only
work on this site when I'm on campus
like they have it routed I don't know
maybe just to my IP like I I can only
access this from this computer so even
if I'm elsewhere on campus on a laptop I
can't can't do it so I don't like being
limited like that but that's kind of the
only I seriously was working here for
like a year and a half before I was
allowed to even have this much access so
I'll take it
Harshit says should I pick Redux or mob
X I'm confused
birdarang xu says mob x is slightly
easier than redux but redux is more
popular yeah I I would agree with that
from what I've from what I've seen from
using redux and from tutorials on mob X
I think mob X is a little bit easier
okay Umberto says he just got to the ass
pronunciation it says it still
pronounced as it as its acronym as far
as I can tell
ASP but I would just stick to calling it
dotnet alright I'll just I'll try to
remember that and just call it dotnet
from now on all right it's always hard
about pronunciation when you work by I
mean I basically work alone most of the
time so I only read normally about how
to pronounce things unless I can find
somebody on YouTube that says it so I
just kind of the first time you read it
you got to decide in your head well how
am I gonna pronounce this thing and
that's usually what what sticks
a Peter S Mac versus windows I'll say
this is my answer for the operating
system question I develop on a Mac my
servers or Linux and I game on a PC or
on a Windows computer so that's that's
how I feel about about operating systems
okay Harshit says any plans for review
I'm getting into it nowadays I don't
have any plans to review right now I'm
interested in it if you want to learn
more about view I would check out
there's a series that we just did here
free code camp not me I mean but Cody
does videos and he just did I think it's
like a five-part series I think there
are five parts there might act there
might end up being more than that of
building something in view from the very
beginning all the way through so I would
check that out I haven't watched it yet
but it seems like it's getting a lot of
views and a lot of thumbs up and stuff
so it seems like it's it's been well
received so far
Harshit says do you use zsh in your
terminal no I just have the the Bosch
just use Bosch for the terminal I mean
like my terminal client is I turned 2
but in terms of like my probe profile
and everything I think that's what
you're asking so let me know if it's not
haha John B says oh the great
pronunciation words I'm still a fan of
the ever looming war of SQL vs sequel I
prefer sequel when it comes to that
unless or why I prefer sequel but I
usually do say sequel but I hear SQL a
lot yeah I don't know why we worry so
much about pronouncing these acronyms
like does it really matter and as long
as you know what the other person is
talking about I don't I don't know that
it matters all right well I've gotten to
the bottom of the live chat if I happen
to miss your question I apologize you
can send me a message on Twitter or
comment on the video or something and
I'll try to get to your question I
should be back tomorrow like I said
there's a chance that I may not stream
tomorrow and I may be working on my my
Redux project so yeah oh I may be
working on it it's given me a lot of
trouble so far so hopefully hopefully a
tomorrow I can stream and say hey I
finished my project and I turned it in
so the chances of that right now don't
seem really good but I can hope right so
I'll be back probably tomorrow I'll let
you know I'll send out a tweet tomorrow
and I'll schedule the stream
as early as I can so you get two
notifications on YouTube if you're
subscribed but until then have a great
day and thanks for so much thank you so
much for watching and contributing in
the live chat and I really appreciate it